[Music]  inflation has been a concern throughout  the pandemic and now it seems to be  creeping into some unusual corners of  our economy that includes the consumer  level bumping the price of everything  from computer chips to the buttons on  your clothes  i have clients literally scouring the  world for  uh  rubber for tires uh cotton for fabric to  make clothing  uh pick it pick a category other than  maybe pharmaceuticals  almost every other industry is impacted  supply chain experts believe the global  system will remain disrupted for at  least another year so consumers should  expect higher prices and shortages to  drag on